-Hey, guys, I'm hanging out with
Gaten Matarazzo.
And we decided to play
"Among Us" with a few friends.
It's an online game where you're
either a crew mate
trying to finish tasks
or an imposter
trying to secretly eliminate
the crew.
We're doing this to raise
money for the charity
Feeding America.
Please donate if you can.
You ready to do this?
-Yes.
♪♪
-Hey, guys, we're gonna play a
few rounds of "Among Us."
Playing with me today, please
welcome from "Stranger Things"
Gaten Matarazzo
and Noah Schnapp.
From "The Roots" we have
Tariq Trotter, Questlove,
and Kirk Douglas.
From the "Among Us" team,
Victoria Tran.
And we have streaming icons,
Sykkuno, Valkyrae,
and of course Corpse Husband.
-Hello.
-Guys, here we go.
Where am I? Oh, I'm the blue.
Alright, I went naked.
I'm Smurf-ing it out.
-Ya naked.
-Smurf.
-Alright, I'm nervous.
-Don't worry, Jimmy.
-Don't worry, Jimmy, we got you.
-These guys bothering you,
Jimmy?
-Yeah.
-Why'd you stand on a vent?
-Hey, back up.
-I didn't stand on a vent.
Stop following me, man.
-You walked right on top of it.
-Get away from me.
Everybody get away from me.
What's going on?
Let me be. Oh, my gosh! No!
-Okay.
-No! Oh, no!
-I think he's the imposter.
-Please!
-I'm thinking he's the imposter.
-Jimmy's definitely the
imposter.
-What color's your name?
What color's your name?
-Stop following me.
Everyone, stop it.
-You're all making Jimmy super
nervous. [ Laughs ]
-I actually almost started
crying right there.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
-Oh, no!
-Ooh!
-Who's dead?
-[ Gasps ]
-Not me.
-Who killed 'Rae?
-Oh, my God, not 'Rae!
-'Rae!
-Alright, I'm gonna say it's
Tariq.
-It definitely wasn't me.
-Wait, why?
-Well, why'd you vote first
though?
-Just because I saw Gaten, like,
hanging out being real random.
-You voted for me?!
-Like he was trying to
prank somebody.
-[ Laughs ]
-You guys, vote Tariq, or he's
gonna kill you all.
-Oh, God.
-Wow.
Wow!
-No!
-He was innocent.
-Y'all did me dirty.
-Kirk, what are you doing on
that vent?!
Oh, Kirk, no! Oh, no!
-I get the feeling
that it might be Kirk.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Guys, emergency meeting.
-Telling you, man, it's Kirk.
-Kirk all the way, dude.
-Why?
-Flipped down the wall.
-Oh, he vented?
-It sounds like it might be
Jimmy.
-No, man, I never saw anyone go
down the vent.
-You're projecting, Jimmy.
-I voted for Kirk.
-I'm thinking it might be Jimmy.
-Look at this, look at this,
watch this.
What a different game we played.
Kirk wa--
[ Cheering ]
-He was one!
-Alright, this mean Jimmy's
innocent, right?
-I never doubted him.
-Guys, everyone stick together.
-I'm confused.
-Hi, Noah.
-Hi, Gabe.
-What's up buddy?
-Oh, God, the door!
Who closed the door?
-Why is it locked?
-The doors are locked.
-You have to wait f-- [Gasps]
-Am I dead or am I in the vents
playing around waiting for you
guys?
-Oh, my God.
-Wait, what.
-Oh, my God. Jimmy just vented.
-Jimmy just vented?
-Jimmy just vented.
-Is Jimmy the other one?
-Wait what?
-Jimmy, you just gave yourself
away.
-Look, look.
Now that we've all voted,
Jimmy didn't actually vent,
didn't actually vent.
-[ Laughs ]
-Actually bad.
-[ Gasps ] It wasn't Jimmy!
-Oh, my gosh!
-Huh.
-Noah did me?
-It was Noah!
-Noah, are you joining me?
-Good job Noah.
-Noah, good job.
That was the real deal.
-You should be an actor.
-Alright, here we go.
This one is for real.
-The real one.
-Alright. No more practice.
-No more practice.
-I just want to
witness a murder.
-Someone's gonna die, someone's
gonna die here.
♪♪
-Oh. Ahh!
-[ Laughs ]
-Yo, I saw my murderer.
-You did?
-Someone decapitated me.
-You guys all hanging out?
Trust.
Trust in the bathroom, dude.
-What? [ Laughs ]
-Just everyone stand on top of
each other. [ Laughs ]
-Why are we all here?
-Because we all gotta
trust each other and
understand that we're a team.
-This game is getting very
clique-ish.
-[ Blows raspberry ]
-Ohh!
-[ Laughs ]
-Kirk's dead. Kirk's dead.
-They killed me.
-The Roots are dead.
-The murderer is wearing
glasses right now.
-It's not me!
-I think it's Sykkuno.
-What?!
-'Rae's the murderer.
-I think that it might be 'Rae.
-'Rae. 'Rae. 'Rae. 'Rae. 'Rae.
-Oh, they're just chanting
"'Rae, 'Rae, 'Rae."
-My God, you guys voted for me.
-My God.
-Are you kidding me?! It's not
Sykkuno. Are you joking?
-You guys are crazy!
Oh, Jesus!
-Oh, I'm [Indistinct]
-Alright.
Two imposters remain.
-It's not 'Rae.
You're trolling.
-'Rae, I can see it
in your glasses reflection.
-[ Laughs ]
-You did? [ Laughs ]
-Corpse, man,
he's on fire tonight.
-Big guess.
-Noah, come here. Come to this
deep, dark corner.
[ Laughs ]
-[ Gasps ] 'Rae!
-Oh, my God! It was 'Rae!
-'Rae took a knife
and decapitated my head off
violently.
-And then laughed at it.
-[ Laughs ]
-'Rae brought me into a corner
and killed me.
-I'm sorry, I'm sorry!
-Game over!
Thank you, guys, for playing.
Thanks for raising a lot of
money for Feeding America.